that's fantastic Mathilda hi I'm Bob
emerging technologies can be very
difficult to master that's why with this
instructional series we're gonna take
you back to school because seniors
nothing keeps you young like learning if
you're like me your children probably
only call you once a month and your wife
is dead the golden years can be pretty
lonely but don't worry modern technology
has the solution online dating start by
searching in the age range of your
choice now I could check for 65 and over
and find someone like my late wife Betty
won't you've outlived your spouse you
don't want to make the same mistake
twice
so I'm gonna say 18 to 25 whoa
how about that there's my granddaughter
Melissa this actually brings up a very
important issue if your granddaughter is
searching for mr. right on her personal
computer it's your responsibility to
protect her as she navigates the shadowy
disease infected world of online dating
through a fun and easy process called
catfishing mmm sounds delicious but put
down your forks and knives because
catfishing is simply an internet slang
term meaning to put on a costume on the
world wide web every day can be
Halloween simply make up a character to
catch her attention think of the type of
boyfriend your granddaughter has dated
in the past there the next step is
engaging her in dialog hello Melissa
I like your profile my name is Kevin
okay it's time to make sure she's making
the right choices and staying safe would
you like to meet up for
sexual intercourse now Melissa will most
likely block my profile
oh no that's not Oh No online dating
there's no need to let the waters of the
internet become a swamp of confusion
catfishing can keep your loved ones safe
and your golden years exciting Melissa
oh no
[Music]
you
[Music]